إنه بعد ظهر يوم السبت وعادة ما
تكون منطقة الوصول مكتظة بالأشخاص
الذين يبحثون عن رحلاتهم إلى المنزل
وما شابه ذلك
اليوم كما ترون لا يوجد أحد هنا
تم تأسيس ثلاث رحلات فقط من أوروبا
لذلك تقول إنك تفتقد السفر
بشغف
هناك الكثير من العلاجات المنزلية لتجعلك
تشعر بالعودة إلى الطريق ، قبطان الطريق يتحدث
آه الأوقات اليائسة التي تتطلب
اتخاذ تدابير يائسة
أشعر أن تجربة السفر هي
النشاط الوحيد الذي يفتح لنا
لقاء مع مايكل بريان عالم نفس السفر
لدينا  اعتادت حياة السفر أن تكون من خلال
عين
الكاميرا لأننا نتساءل عما إذا كنا سنتمكن من
التجول مرة أخرى
، يقول إنه من المفيد أن
نتذكر سبب حبنا
للسفر في المقام الأول عندما تسافر إلى
الخارج أو إلى مكان جديد
كل شيء  يفتح مرة أخرى لديك
توقعات مبهجة
ويعطي المزيد من الاحتمالات
وتخمين ما
هو آمن نسبيًا إنه مجزٍ جدًا
لأنه يبني خداعنا الذاتي  أثق على تقديرنا
لذاتنا وأعتقد أننا أصبحنا أكثر من الأشخاص
الذين نريد أن نكون
[موسيقى]
ربما كان ذلك حنينًا
إلى الأيام الخوالي عندما كان السفر
سهلاً ،
هذه العجائب ، هل لديك هذا
يا فتى ، هل لدي ذلك؟  لقد كان دائمًا ما
أه ، ويمكن أن يصبح
أفضل منك ، أعني فقط التفكير في
التخيل الذي نفعله عندما نكون
عالقين كما قلت
يوم العمل الذي يبلغ 48 ساعة ، آه ، لم أنجز الكثير
ولكن  أنا أتوق إلى حرية الخروج من
هذا
واستئناف مغامرتى ذاك
الشعور بضرورة الخروج إلى هناك
مرة أخرى ،
أفتقد أبواب طاقم المقصورة تلقائيًا
، أفقد طعام شركة الطيران الذي أفتقده فقط
إلى مدينة أخرى
تخبرني بأنك أعيش معها ، لكن من
الطبيعي أن أعيش معها ، وأتمنى
وأتوقع وأعتقد أننا سنعود إلى
الحياة الطبيعية مرة أخرى ونخمن ما سنقدره أكثر
من
ذلك بكثير
[  الموسيقى]
السفر في أوقات الإصابة بالفيروس ليس بالأمر السهل
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يمكنهم فعل ذلك ، فهو لا يزال
يستحق العناء
و  أو أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون التفكير في
الرحلات الرائعة المقبلة عندما يمكنك
أخيرًا
السفر وهذا هو سفر رجال الأعمال 4 هذا
الشهر ، أنا ريتشارد كويست
على متن الطائرة
أينما تأخذك رحلاتك ، وآمل أن
تكون رحلة آمنة مربحة